- I'm enjoying the negativity
because it's become such a
fuckin' thing I'm used to
that when joy is put into
my life, it's confusing,
and I just start crying
and fucking getting lost.
I don't know what to fuckin' do.
I'm not ready for change, I guess.
Like if I had a self-destruct button,
I'd just probably
fuckin' hit it right now.
- [Mark] All right, John,
John, now where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from Chicago.
- [Mark] Tell me about your family.
You had both parents when you were a kid?
- My mom, she just been
kinda like using me
for child support money on and off.
Dad, in and out of jail.
His last case was for a 12 ATM
heist that he pled guilty to.
Closed a couple of cases
and basically get a shorter sentence.
I've been on and off the
street from like 16 on.
- [Mark] What was your childhood like?
- Just kicked out of school, after school,
going between parents,
grandparents, and shelter.
Basically I don't know
exactly where it started
between getting touched or abused.
I mean, I had a pretty wild stepdad
that didn't favor me out of the bunch,
and even if I was in the right,
it was looked at as a wrong.
I remember like being dragged
and picked up by a belt around my neck,
shaken, thrown across the room at the bed,
hitting the wall in between
the bed and the floor.
Just led to a drug use at
a young age and even more
pedophilic people being around me.
- [Mark] When did you come to L.A.?
- About (vibrates lips) three
to four years ago, I'd say.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- 28.
And you're staying on Skid Row?
- Yeah, I'm staying in a
tent next to my brother.
- [Mark] What's your drug today?
- Fentanyl, every now and then I do black,
I smoke crystal, and
lately I've been kinda
like messing around with
Sherm, but not really.
- [Mark] And drug use
started at what age for you?
- Phew, oh, man, like nine years old.
I'd say I found my dad's
weed at a young age,
and I didn't even know what I was doing.
I tried rolling it up in computer paper
and almost caught my closet on fire.
Then I started doing coke,
then really quickly
turned to crack cocaine,
where me and my dad were just picking up
like an ounce a day to two ounces a day,
selling it to like my friends and shit.
And then I was also doing
acid, shrooms, Ecstasy.
Every day was a different
drug, and me chasing the drug,
whether pills, everything.
I've had my like dip in everything.
- [Mark] What would you put your finger on
as being the reason that
you started with drug use?
- Disassociation from my
kid, you know, missing him.
- [Mark] Oh, so you have a child?
- Yeah, I mean, lately,
I've been like having
problems coping with emotions
and I think it does have
something to do with being raped,
but it comes out in bits and pieces,
and, like, I'm not...
I don't know exactly how to put it.
Like, I'm emotional on a
day to day. I'm a wreck.
And I wake up, just constantly,
the first thing I think about is suicide.
My friends look at me like I'm crazy,
and I can't even really
talk to 'em about it.
- [Mark] This happens to you every day?
- Yeah. Every single day.
Actually, this morning,
as I recall. (chuckles)
First thing. And then I have
to clean up after everybody.
While everybody else
just doesn't give a fuck,
I'm constantly being put the
stress and pressure on the most
about cleaning the block and
taking care of everybody else
while dealing with mental issues
that nobody gives a fuck about.
It's just, it's fuckin' haywire.
- [Mark] How are you
supporting yourself now?
- I boost. I go out every
day and I rob stores.
I go in with trash bags sometimes,
and I just start filling up
in front of the security,
and they'll trace me around
the store a little bit,
and I'll fuckin' play cat and mouse.
And then I'll run out the store,
and then I'll go to the fuckin'...
I'm not gonna say the area,
but, you know, I go
sell it to the Mexicans,
and I get my little money,
and I go get my fix.
- [Mark] The fences.
- Yeah, fences.
- [Mark] They're called fences?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] And that's how
you support yourself?
- Yeah, that, and, I mean,
here and there prostitution
when it's I see like profitable,
which had me also questioning sexuality,
whether I'm straight or not.
It's confusing.
- [Mark] So you're
basically a straight male,
but you're being propositioned.
You're given an opportunity to make money?
- Yeah.
- From other males?
- It's making it, make me
wonder, "Am I straight?"
And I look at other gays and I'm like,
"Okay, when did you become gay?"
And they're like, "Oh, I've
been gay my whole life."
And I'm just like, "That's
not the case with me."
You know, I still like women,
but I could get erect for a male.
And I don't know if that's
the drug's doing it,
or if it's just the so much of abuse
and like I just kinda
zone out during the time
and just get it done.
I take that pain and I just go on with it.
There's really no more than I could say,
that I could do with that part
besides take it. (chuckles)
When you need a fix, and you gotta get it,
you gotta get it at that point.
When it gets to the point
where you're so sick,
and you can't think,
it's like you got a
demon on your shoulder,
and you got an angel on your shoulder.
And the angel is just constantly
getting pushed off the shoulder,
and the devil is just
fuckin' standing tall.
You know, he's just like,
"Fuck it, what is it?
What is your fuckin' sexuality?
What is another day of abuse?
You could be fuckin'
high for three, four days
and not have to think about it."
- [Mark] What do you think
others that don't do drugs
don't understand about addiction?
- Everything.
I look at other people
and I feel like I'm not
even a human anymore.
- [Mark] But the power of it.
Like, people will say, "Well,
you speak intelligently.
You seem like an educated person,
and you're making these decisions
that are so self-destructive and outside-"
- I've been just suicidal, I guess.
I've just been so like hate towards myself
for giving up on my kid
even though I really
don't want to, you know?
It's just I can't be there for him,
and I did a lot to fuckin'
make my shit on point
with schooling and working.
And then when my dad
just didn't give a fuck,
and then the blackmailing,
and the baby mama thinking I'm fucking
some Black girl that was way before her,
but she every time fuckin',
"Go fuck that Black bitch!"
I'm not doing shit, I'm in school,
and you think I'm fuckin' doing some...
I'm in school, I'm working,
and I'm come and taking off the day,
getting yelled at by my boss,
to take you to the hospital
for a twisted fuckin'
ankle, and then I gotta go,
and you're just like,
"All right, I'ma do me."
What do you mean you're gonna do you?
What did I do to deserve that, you know?
So I just, I eventually
stopped talking to her,
and it's become this point
where I don't know how
to get back into my son's life, you know?
I don't know how to jump back in
and start a conversation with
him 'cause he's getting older,
and it's just terrifying to me.
And that's bringing so
much fuckin' stress.
- [Mark] Is it the shame?
- Yeah. Total fuckin' shame.
I feel like such a fuckin' loser.
That's how I feel like
everybody looks at me too.
Every now and then I fuckin'...
I might be bipolar, and I'm like getting
into a different like Superman mode
where like I'm making money,
but it doesn't continually stay that way
or escalate to where
I'm making it, you know?
I'm always in between
the bullshit and a fix,
and I feel like my whole life
is gonna continue down this
until I fuckin' deteriorate,
and my son won't even
know who the fuck I am.
(sirens wailing)
- [Mark] Do you have any friends?
- Yeah, I've got a very large
amount of friends, actually.
(sirens wailing)
I consider them more
of like a, basically,
highly organized trade market more.
Like, we get high together.
We share our stories kinda.
But at the end of the day,
we're all trying to get somewhere,
so we really don't give
a fuck about each other.
We'd probably turn our backs on each other
more than we fuckin' shake hands.
- [Mark] So they're more like
acquaintances than friends?
- Yeah.
Do you feel like you were ever
loved when you were young,
when you were a child?
- Yeah, for a small period
of time in my life until...
My grandpa, he had a secret life going on
with a Black girl from Georgia,
and like, he just randomly
brought her to Greece with us
when we went out there for the summer,
and that was last year I went out there.
He was just like, "Surprise,
this is my daughter.
This is her daughter. This
is your dad's sister."
And it felt like that point,
that's when everything went downhill.
It didn't bother me so much,
but it's almost like a
curse was put on my family.
I don't know. It's very weird.
Nobody even seen it coming, you know?
My dad, he seemed to know about it though,
and he was okay with it.
My grandma, she's torn up by it.
Led her into fuckin' mental deterioration,
physical deterioration.
She died young. Grandpa got to go retire.
He just recently died this year
out in retirement in Greece
on an island called Milos.
This island, I'd go out
every year up until 2008.
At that point, I was a mockery
to the family name basically.
I was an alcoholic out there.
Most kids would be like,
"Oh, I'm in Greece,"
and they go swimming, blah, blah, blah.
I was trying to get drunk
every fuckin' minute.
And I sunk a boat.
I fuckin' was punching out windows
and just showing 'em like weird signs
that something wasn't right.
And instead of trying to
fix it, I was shunned.
I was looked at like...
Actually made fun of as I recall.
They would call me Little Jessica
or they refer to my parents' names,
which they were fuckin' idiots.
The family out in Greece,
they just act a lot higher
than what I was or my family was.
So we all just got outcasted
and nobody got to talk to him.
Nobody knew what happened.
The only reason I know
that my grandpa died
was because I kept up with social media
and other people posting on his profile.
I'm actually named after him,
so it's pretty fucked up to
see his last several years,
I didn't even get to talk to him.
You know, it's crazy.
I was some small shit in somebody's life.
Somebody would just give up on you,
just throw you out like you're trash.
- [Mark] Do you have hope for your future?
- I did, but nowadays,
I just feel like
everything's a waste of time.
I used to have dreams. I used
to think I could make music.
I used to think I could draw new tattoos.
And I know I could cook,
but I don't wanna be everybody's
all the fuckin' time,
and fuckin' clean this and cook that,
and barely show any appreciation
towards like for cooking.
Like anybody could fuckin'
cook. It's a very simple thing.
You put somebody in a kitchen,
a year or two later, the man's a cook.
That's all that happened there.
You know, fuckin'
even I had like all the
fuckin' funds imaginable
to make my career that I
wanted back when I was younger,
I would probably just waste
more time doing drugs.
Nowadays, it just seems like
my dog is the only thing I got,
and even there, I'm like
considering selling her
just to get high, and it's fucked up.
I've spent a lot of money on her
just to throw it all away.
I don't know, it just seems
like there's nothing you can do
to cast these demons out of you.
Once they're in you,
they just keep getting at you
to eat till you've had enough.
And it just isn't a comment.
It's not something you're
saying under your breath.
You just eventually take your life.
- [Mark] Has depression
always been something
you've dealt with or has this-
- Yeah.
- Increased?
- First time I tried killing myself,
it was like nine years old.
I was an inpatient.
I was in, (scoffs) I
had to get sent to Utah,
Salt Lake City, at 13 and do
the fuckin' inpatient there.
I got kicked out for
giving a kid a concussion,
making his jaw pop every time it opened
after pissing on his
head and waking him up.
I don't know.
I feel psychotic like most
of the time, actually.
I'm not only the abused; I'm the abuser.
People say the person that gets abused
eventually becomes that person.
I sometimes feel like
I'm becoming that person.
And like my whole life, I've just thought,
"I'm gonna be that dog that
ends up in a fuckin' cell,
and there's nothing I can do."
It's just gonna eventually
lead to me killing people
every time I get within contact of people.
Or self-isolation, just
locked in a fuckin' cell.
Not even a cell. There is no fuckin' bars.
It's just a fuckin' cement
room, with a little tiny window,
with your food thrown at you,
soaking in your own piss
and sweat. (sighs heavily)
- [Mark] And the life you're
living now doesn't really help?
- There's no other choice though.
- [Mark] No, I know.
I mean, just to survive,
you need to steal or have sex with guys?
- Yeah, sex with anything.
Trannies too. Anything, pfft.
I literally can zone out and do
basically what ketamine does
to the body without ketamine.
Like, everything's just gone.
And I could put on a persona of somebody
that I'm not just a fuckin'
achievement objective
to lead to my fuckin' numbing.
- [Mark] Have you ever had therapy?
- Yeah, it never seemed to help though.
I always just mocked it.
I thought it was stupid.
I just everyday seeing it as like,
"All right, everybody, let's go to group,
and let's write our goals."
And it's just fucking retarded.
Talking about it does not fucking help.
It just brings it back into my brain,
and it makes me sit and ponder on it more
than just letting it go
and trying to push it away.
It really just seems like
the drug is the only thing
that cures it nowadays.
That's the only thing.
The whole time, it's just, even then,
suicide actually really
is all I could. (sighs)
I've been thinking about
just getting myself out of this life.
Just fuck the drugs. Really
the drug is just temporary.
- [Mark] You ever been clean?
- Very short period of
time, and I was a cook.
I offered my baby mama to
come move out to Georgia
and be a stay-at-home mom,
and she just rather stay in Chicago
in the fuckin' cut, in the ghetto,
and fuckin' raise her son
amongst different dudes
that she just bounces off
of, getting abused by.
And then I snapped and
said, "All right, fuck this.
What am I working for?
I can't get my son back.
She's unwilling to work with me.
And I'm just constantly
putting out as this bad person,
so fuck it, I'm gonna
become the bad person."
I'm not gonna be called
something I'm not, you know?
And just people day to day,
like, I can't stand people.
I really can't.
Like even my own friends, I
tell them to shut the fuck up,
and I feel like killing them
even when they're trying
to be compassionate with me
and show me the time that I need.
Like, it's just, I'll be out of my head,
and so fucking much filth.
I can't stand it, and
I literally just snap.
Second I wake up, I start snapping
to the second I go to bed.
- [Mark] Do you ever have good days?
- No, not really.
I always seem to find the
depression in everything
more than the joy.
Everything, just I could
always, since a young age,
without the news having to be played,
and just see everything
that's going around
with corona and all the stupid shit,
I could see it like physically,
like the good and evil in life, but
I'm almost enjoying the evil,
like I'm enjoying the negativity
because it's become such a
fuckin' thing I'm used to
that when joy is put into
my life, it's confusing,
and I just start crying
and fucking getting lost.
I don't know what to fuckin' do.
I'm not ready for change, I guess.
Like if I had a self-destruct button,
I'd just probably
fuckin' hit it right now.
- [Mark] You ever talked to a doctor
about brain chemistry
or anything like that?
- I've studied brain
chemistry, psychologic.
- [Mark] Yeah, but doctors
have studied brain chemistry,
and they're still experimenting.
- Shit, the last fuckin' trick
that I was pulling was a psychiatrist.
Used to write fuckin'
Xanny Bars off to people.
It just shows how many pedophilic people
that are out in this world,
even the motherfuckin' richest,
and people that are looked
at as high and mighty
can be the fuckin' most
weirdest and tormenting
to some of the most fucking
fragile people out here.
'Cause you don't see them
on a day-to-day basis.
You don't see them when they're,
"Hey, do you fool around?
You wanna fuck me in my ass?"
Like, you know what kind of
question you're asking me?
Do you know what that does
to my brain when I hear that?
It makes me wanna contemplate killing you
and dragging you off under a sewer pate
and dropping you into the fucking ground.
I think about that daily.
Actually, I think about
hunting people daily.
I think about going out
and killing people daily.
And my friends, actually,
I could even get my friends
to probably join me.
I feel like fuckin' Manson,
like only targeting more
the pedophilic nature.
Every time I get a whiff of somebody
that's supposedly a little
more fuckin' psychotic,
I almost wanna go out and kill 'em.
I just got wind of somebody
that supposedly tried burning
up a 13-year-old girl's body
after raping her and killing.
He lives right down the street from here
and he's still fuckin'
running around in the street.
I just wanna go kill him.
My friend wants to go kill him.
He's been raped too, fuckin'...
A lot of my friends have been
put through the same shit,
and they can understand,
and that's what's even more disgusting.
It's like, I'm not just now,
I guess I'm maybe not just
one out of fuckin' a million.
No, I'm like one out of fuckin' 99.
And there's maybe 1% people out here,
they're fuckin' normal,
and it just seems that they're all normal.
Sorry. I zoned out for a second.
- It's okay.
I don't know
what I was thinking about.
- [Mark] Do you have a
lot of dark stuff going on
in your head?
- Yeah.
I sometimes zone out a lot.
I don't know. I kinda hear voices too,
but I can't tell if I'm like
really hearing them or I am,
and like people, that's another
reason I snap on people.
They'll be saying shit,
but they don't make themselves loud enough
to where you can hear them,
so then like my brain confuses
me into making it think
that they're saying
something sexual towards me
under their breaths and
nobody else hears it.
And I threatened to kill
this dude the other day,
who we hang out with on a daily basis,
'cause he's just mumbling.
He smokes crystal. He
can't really be heard.
And I thought he was saying
something about my dick
or his dick or something.
I'm like, "You wanna
say it a little louder
so I have a reason to
fuckin' cut your throat?
'Cause I'll drag you out
fuckin' butt-ass naked,
and throw you out this tent
and have your little dick in the wind
while I beat you to fuckin' death
in the middle of the street."
And I honestly am not
afraid to go to jail,
like I'm almost welcoming it.
It's probably the place that I belong.
I feel like a possible threat, you know?
I need to be put out of my misery
so I don't destroy more lives
that don't deserve to be destroyed.
Part of me doesn't wanna be that abuser,
but I just can't help it.
It's too much overriding the brain,
and it's just doing what it knows,
what it sees, what it hears.
Monkey see, monkey do.
- [Mark] Would you consider going
to like a mental health place
and seeing what they can do to help you?
- Honestly, no.
The only way you're gonna get me
in a little room is by
locking me in the little room
because I wanna be numb.
I can't fuckin' handle
sitting there dealing
with the bullshit and people
that don't really give a fuck.
They're there for a paycheck.
- [Mark] No, but somebody that
might give you a medication
that might help calm-
- I've tried medications.
They're so fuckin' stupid.
They don't even know what the fuck
they're prescribing me half the time.
This dude prescribed me twice
with shit that was like knocking me out,
and then they were yelling
at me for knocking out.
I couldn't control it.
Literally, I was physically blacking out.
I was in group and
literally I was kicked out
of the whole pizza party and
everything, and I flipped out
and destroyed the whole
fucking unit and left rehab
because there's some idiot
just prescribing me whatever.
"Oh, we're going to give you
Depakote," and this and that,
"and we'll see how you act,
and we'll read your charts,
and go on forth from there."
I can bullshit and lie 'cause
I'm confused at the time
and just get me put into
taking more medications
that don't really physically help
'cause I wanna get out
of there at the time.
So I will tell you, "Oh,
yeah, everything's all right.
(chuckles) I'm totally ready to leave."
But really, I might be that killer today.
I might come out in these
streets and fucking kill somebody
if I see enough money
in their fuckin' hand.
- [Mark] Do you think
talking about it helps you
or hurts you?
- I don't know, honestly.
It feels like the blood
is getting to my head
and I'm gonna black out when I think-
(Mark chuckling)
As much.
- [Mark] I'll give you a break.
We'll put a stop to it today.
But if you wanna come back.
- Sure.
- You're welcome to come back.
There's somebody else
that I talked to, James,
when I first started doing this
that had really, really
dark thoughts all the time.
He claimed he was killing
pedophiles on the street.
- I probably knew him.
- [Mark] I'll show you a photo
or I'll show you the video.
- I'd love to see it.
- [Mark] He had a lot
of dark stuff going on.
- There's a lot of gay guys
coming up missing actually.
Not missing, found, actually,
with their hands handcuffed,
pants below their waist, throat cut,
and is believed to be a serial killer
right by where I was staying
'cause they found the body one block away.
And then there was also a
dude killing all the girls
that do fentanyl in MacArthur Park.
But he disappeared for awhile.
I don't know where he's at.
I don't know if I'd kill
him, or if I joined him.
I'd honestly first want to see why.
If he's killing pedophiles, yeah,
then that's all the
power to him, you know?
But then eventually
there's gotta be the point
where I gotta kill myself
'cause I'm starting to become
that sick, demented fuck
that would probably pay some fuckin' ho
to fuckin' do some crazy shit to me.
And not will have, I've already done,
like I've done stupid shit with my money,
throwing it away sexually
to just fucking be miserable still.
It doesn't really complete
or make me feel like I completed any goal.
And I some bad bitches, but...
These fucking...
They're so fuckin' confusing
in the way they come on.
They make you confused
about your own sexuality.
They make you think that they care,
and they're compassionate,
and that's what you need.
You don't need some bitch
that's gonna keep fuckin'
running around, cheating on you,
and making you wanna go after
her and fuckin' choke her out.
Maybe it's just not about the sex anymore.
It's just about that fuckin' maturity
and someone to talk to that
cares and is on the same level.
But then it always comes back to the sex.
They wanna do something weird to you.
I've been drugged.
I have people try to drug me
a lot of the time, actually.
They fuckin' hand me Sherm sticks
when they're passing a normal one around
and make it seem like they're
gonna pass me a normal one,
but then it's not.
Like I don't know the difference
and I can't smell it, you know?
I've smelled bath salt accidentally once.
This gay dude fuckin' handed it to me,
and I didn't know I was
the only one smoking it.
They were smoking another pipe.
I started freaking out
for like two, three days.
I couldn't handle the hearing.
Every little vision or
reflection of me looked demonic
like it wasn't me looking back at myself.
And I literally just wanted to find a hill
in the middle of nowhere,
where it just was quiet,
and I could just zone away from that.
I had people trying to
turn me into inpatient
'cause I was literally,
I wouldn't come down
for like two, three days after that point.
I was in Portland at that time.
I've stayed in Washington.
I've stayed in Portland.
I've stayed in California.
Basically all of the fuckin' West Coast.
I've stayed in Idaho.
And some of the East Coast too.
Fuckin' West Coast always seemed
to be more fuckin' life-threatening.
- [Mark] What's been
the worst neighborhood
you've stayed in?
- Shit, my own. (chuckles) Yeah, Chicago.
I mean, there's never a day
where you can't find everybody
that you're in relation to,
to walk down the street
just to get something
without getting jumped
or the police stopping you and being like,
"Yeah, we had a jump thing going on,
and you're suspected of being
the leading result of that
because your tattoos," or whatever.
And I'm just trying to get a two liter
and get back to the grill and
maintain my fire and my food,
and now I gotta come back
to burnt-ass fuckin' shit
because they wanna fuckin' prosecute me
for some shit that I didn't even do.
- [Mark] What neighborhood
in Chicago were you?
- Cicero.
It became though,
between me and my family,
being a part of one gang
and then staying out of a
house of my dad's friend
who is in another gang, they're rivals,
but we low key click.
It was very hard to do and control
because other people did not like that,
and it had to be though, you know?
We had nowhere to stay.
That was after my dad going MIA
from fuckin' basically what he started
because he was becoming a crack head.
It was against the fucking
gang rules, you know?
They didn't preach that whole bullshit
that people are out on...
Here, they don't give a fuck, you know?
Every gang, I've come across gangs
where they don't give a shit
if one of your members is
a rapist or this or that.
They don't care.
Out there, we take care
of that shit, you know?
I mean, you better take care
of that shit if you see it;
otherwise, you'll be fuckin'
beat for it, you know?
It was just constant
violations over nothing.
Violations for not going
to church. Violations...
Church is fuckin' basically meet up time.
Once out the week,
everybody has to come in
and fuckin' relay on
what's going the fuck on,
if you see anything going on in the hood,
anything that needs to be dealt with.
It's very a white gang,
started in the '60s,
but it's like now starting to show more
like Puerto Rican members
and some Black members.
- [Mark] This is Chicago?
- Yeah. Simon City Royals.
Fuckin' it's kinda branched out,
and it's becoming something
that wasn't back then.
But I've kind of escaped that life.
I was sick of it.
I just didn't want it to go on anymore.
It was controlling my life.
I didn't have a choice in
if I did try to open
my mouth and say like,
"Oh, man, I don't feel like it right now."
Like, "Man, you being
a bitch, dawg, come on!
Like, "You're gonna let me fuckin' go deal
with this shit by myself
after you've been riding
with me this whole time?"
There is none of that. No.
When you join in, you join in,
and it's sacrifice to
the fuckin' human soul.
You literally put your life on the line.
I guess that's kinda where coming in
with the killing pedophilic people off.
We don't like that nature,
you know? It's shunned.
Anything gay is shunned, really.
It's very un-liberal
in Chicago. (chuckles)
- [Mark] All right, John.
Well, thank you for coming
in and talking with me.
If you wanna come back any time.
- Definitely.
- Let me know.
Sounds like you have a
lot going on in your head.
- Now I do, yeah.
(John and Mark chuckling)
(John exhales sharply)